je suis persuadé
nous avons tous notre madeleine de
proust ce fameux plat cet aliment qui
lorsqu on le mange fait resurgir en nous
toute une palette d'émotions et de
sensations directement lié à un souvenir
un moment très précis de notre vie est
en général très éloigné dans le temps
alors aujourd'hui j'aimerais partager
avec vous l'une de ses madeleines une
tranche de vie je vous l'offre
alors manger c'est quelque chose que
nous connaissons tous nous le faisons
tous les jours ça mobilise nos cinq sens
à la fois notamment le goût et l'odorat
l'odorat qui correspond en majeure
partie à ce que nous pensons être le
goût d'un aliment mais qui en fait
correspond aux arômes que nous percevons
par rétro olfaction et la mémoire
olfactive d'après les spécialistes
serait l'une des plus hautes persistante
à l'épreuve du temps par rapport aux
autres mémoire sensorielle ou parce
qu'elle permettrait d'enregistrer une
odeur en même temps que tout son
contexte émotionnel et les occasions que
nous avons de manger correspondent très
souvent à des contextes émotionnel fort
un repas c'est l'occasion de se réunir
autour d'une table de partager
d'échanger de débattre de s'émouvoir de
créer du lien social
alors justement moi je suis l'auteur
d'un blog culinaire dans lequel je
propose des recettes mais également leur
histoire j'explique dans quel contexte
je les ai goûté pour la première fois
inventé pour certaines je raconte la ou
les personnes le souvenir le moment la
saison qui me l'ont inspiré et je pense
que nous avons tous connu plusieurs fois
dans notre vie de réelles émotions
culinaire alors moi la madeleine que je
veux partager avec vous ce n'est pas une
madeleine mais plutôt un flan
c'est une des recettes les plus
consultés sur mon blog elle s'intitule
flan coco le secret de gaël je devais
avoir 12 ans et j'ai été invité à
l'anniversaire de ma copine gaël vous
avions pas c'est une formidable après
midi entre copines à discuter à jouer
puis est arrivée l'heure du goûter et le
moment pour gaël de souffler ses bougies
d'anniversaire qui sont arrivés sur un
magnifique flanc comme celui ci ça
ressemblait à une couche de gâteaux à la
noix de coco surmonté d'un flan caramel
j'en garde un souvenir je n'avais jamais
rien à manger d'une légèreté d'une
gourmandise comparables est donc
évidemment je me suis empressé de
demander à gaël farseth de flan coco
qu'elle m'a transmise sur cette feuille
à grands carreaux décoré par ses soins
et que depuis tout ce temps j'ai
conservé très précieusement si gaël
savez aujourd'hui que sa recette fait le
tour du web
je me demande comment elle réagirait et
ce qui est intéressant c'est que il ya
quelques semaines de cela je reçois sur
mon blog
le commentaire d'une dame à propos de ce
flan coco elle me dit bonjour j'ai une
subite envie de savourer ce délice
d'enfance est impossible de retrouver ma
recette de flan coco
j'ai retourné toute la maison rien à
faire c'est ainsi que j'ai découvert
votre blog très sympa gaël est ce que
c'est toi qui avait donné cette recette
à cette dame étonnant j'ai compris que
non seulement nous avions tous une et
même plusieurs madeleine de proust mais
qu'en plus nous pouvions en avoir en
commun avec des gens complètement
inconnu et qu'elle pouvait faire
allusion au même type de souvenirs et en
cela je trouve que la pâtisserie tient
une place toute particulière
avec ces gourmandises d'enfance colorée
sucrée
ces odeurs de four ces odeurs qui
embaume toute une maison
ces gros gâteau à partager tous ensemble
pour des occasions spéciales
et pour moi ce sont les premiers moments
que j'ai partagé dans une cuisine avec
ma mère c'est pour cela que j'ai décidé
d'être pâtissière c'est un métier où
l'on procure de vrai plaisir aux gens
qui demande aussi beaucoup de créativité
et une technique un savoir-faire très
précis et il faut également bien
comprendre les réactions chimiques
physiques biologiques qui peuvent
intervenir entre les différents
ingrédients par exemple c'est en école
de pâtisserie que j'ai appris que la
matière grasse pouvait avoir une
importance capitale dans la réalisation
de certaines préparations la quantité de
beurre cacao de beurre de cacao contenus
dans le chocolat va faire qu'on va
pouvoir le travailler et ensuite le fer
cristallisé correctement est ce que vous
saviez que la quantité de matière grasse
dans une crème liquide est capital pour
pouvoir la faire émulsionner en chantier
vous pouvez essayer avec une crème demi
écrémé vous n'y arriverez pas donc la
pâtisserie oui depuis ma plus tendre
enfance j'ai goûté mais il ya la cuisine
aussi et ça c'est arrivé un petit peu
plus tard j'étais alors étudiant talion
en école de commerce
et puis là je me suis retrouvé dans mon
petit studio loin du cocon familial et
bon faut bien continuer à se nourrir
n'est ce pas et donc là j'avais deux
solutions soit je pouvais manger des
choses très basiques des pâtes des
pizzas surgelées des packs des plats
cuisinés qui avait plus qu'à réchauffer
ou bien mais je me retrousser les
manches et puis bah je m'étais la main à
la pâte à proprement parler et c'est
bien entendu ce que j'ai fait parce que
pour moi il était inconcevable de ne pas
retrouver tout ce que j'avais connu chez
mes parents j'avais besoin de reproduire
s'est placée haut
d'ailleurs ces saveurs qui m'était
familière et puis bon je suis une
terrible gourmande et il faut dire que
je suis issu d'une famille où la
tradition culinaire est particulièrement
forte
ma mère et philippine mon père est
franco vietnamien et je partage ma vie
avec un italien donc c'est dire si
j'évolue dans un mix culturel qui place
vraiment la nourriture au centre de tout
chez moi
un repas ça se partage tous ensemble
autour d'une table et donc un jour j'ai
ressenti le besoin de transmettre cet
héritage cultive urinaires et j'ai eu
besoin de partager cet amour et cette
passion pour la cuisine
ce que j'ai fait à travers mon blog
alors oui au départ c'était sur mon
temps libre
le week end le soir je rentrais d'une
journée éprouvante à auditer des comptes
de sociétés financières et je me mettais
aux fourneaux et j'en avais besoin ça me
faisait du bien ça me relaxe est je me
recentrer sur moi même et là je me
faisait vraiment plaisir et donc par la
force des choses et bien la cuisine est
devenu le centre de tous mes projets et
de mes activités et donc ben oui je dois
vous avouer que mes parents ils ont eu
un peu de mal à digérer cette
reconversion professionnelle et
aujourd'hui ils digèrent très très bien
toutes mes pâtisseries vous dire que
c'est quand même grâce à eux que j'en
suis arrivé là c'est quand même eux qui
m'ont transmis ce goût et cette passion
pour les bonnes choses dès le début et
aujourd'hui je suis très heureuse de me
retrouver dans une école de commerce
moi même diplômé d'une école de commerce
pour vous dire que aujourd'hui je suis
pâtissière de profession
demain je veux ouvrir mon propre salon
de thé donc vous voyez que ce parcours
qui au départ semblait commencer par une
erreur d'orientation de choix était en
fait parfaitement logique et prend tout
son sens donc je pense qu'il faut pas
avoir peur de ces choix de ce que l'on
ressent allez vraiment vers ce qui vous
passionne vers ce qui vous fait vibrer
et posez-vous cette simple question et
moi quelle est ma madeleine de proust